TUCKER CARLSON.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT" THE PRESIDENT MADE HIS
CATION FOR WHY AMERICA NEEDS A
WALL ON HIS SOUTHERN BOARDER AND
WHY THAT WALL IS SO PERSONALITY
THAT HE'S SHUTTING DOWN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET T.
DEMOCRATS REMAIN REMOVED BY THE
ADDRESS.
AND DEMOCRATS, CHUCK SHOUPER AND
NANCY PELOSI, THEIR WORDS WERE
ECHOED WITH MECHANICAL PRECISION
UP AND DOWN THE CHAIN, GRANTING
A MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, AND DOWN
TO THE LADY MUTTERING  IN THE
DOG PARK.
IT'S LIKE WATCHING  A 3D PRINTER
AT WORK, TURNING OUT CARBON
COPIES OF PROPAGAND A ONE AFTER
THE OTHER, AFTER THE OTHER.
A MIRACLE OF REPLICATION.
YOU MIGHT EVEN CALL THE
DEMOCRATIC RESPONSE MANUFACTURE
MANUFACTURED.
>> THIS IS A MANUFACTURED CRISIS
AND A CRISIS THAT IS
MANUFACTURED BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> THIS IS A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS, BILL.
>> HOW HE MANUFACTURES CRISES
LIKE IMMIGRANTS, SEEKING LEGAL
REFUGE.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS DOING,
IS MANUFACTURING A CRISIS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST STOP
HOLDING AMERICANS HOSTAGE AND
STOP MANUFACTURING A CRISIS.
>> THIS PRESIDENT JUST USED THE
BACKDROP OF THE OVAL OFFICE TO
MANUFACTURE A CRISIS.
>> SO THEY BROUGHT BACK
MANUFACTURING.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRESS?
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS SAYING T
REPORTERS ARE SAYING IT, TOO.
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS, YOU OFTEN
COMPLAIN THAT YOUR CONSERVATIVES
ARE LIBERAL, THAT'S GIVING THEM
FAR TOO MUCH CREDIT AWAY.
THEY REALLY ARE, ARE OBED IANT.
IF NANCY PELOSI CALLED FOR
INVADING CANADA TOMORROW, ALL
THE NEWS ANCHORS WOULD BE
TELLING YOU HOW OTTAWA IS THE
REAL 38.
THEY'RE FLUNKIES, HUMAN
FLUNKIES, DOING THEIR JOB AT
WORK.
>> FOLKS, THE PRESIDENT HAS
MANUFACTURED ONE HECK OF A
POLITICAL CRISIS FOR HIMSELF.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS MANUFACTURE
AID CRISIS.
>> THIS IS A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS.
IT'S NOT A NATIONAL SECURITY
>> FROM NANCY PELOSI, DOWN TO
DEBBIE WATSON SHUTTER.
ANYONE WHO WILL GIVE HIM A DIME
FOR THIS PROJECT.
>> IT'S A MANUFACTURED CRISIS
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO GET A
POLITICAL END.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO WILL
GO ON TV TONIGHT AND LIE AND LIE
AND LIE SOME MORE, THIS IS A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
>> THEY'RE SO DUMB.
THEY HAVE NO SELF-RESPECT.
SO WE SHOWED YOU THE MINDS OF
THE LIES THEY ARE TELLING.
A WHAT ARE DEMOCRATS PROPOSING
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE BORDER
WALL.
LAST WEEK ON JANUARY 3, HOUSE
DEMOCRATS PASSED THEIR OWN
PROPOSAL, THEY SAY WILL SECURE
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
WHAT'S WHAT'S IN IT?
WHAT WOULD IT DO?
NOTHING THAT'S NOT BEING DONE
ALREADY.
DEMOCRATIC BILL PROVIDE IT IS
THE SAME FUNDING FOR PARTIAL
FENCING, HIRING MORE CUSTOMS
OFFICE, SO FORTH, THAT WE
ALREADY V. A DEMOCRATIC BORDER
SECURITY PLAN IS THE STATUS QUO.
DEMOCRAT'S ARGUMENT IS THINGS
WERE JUST -- WORK JUST FINE
RIGHT NOW.
INSTEAD OF SPENDING ANOTHER
DOLLAR TO SECURE THE BORDER,
DEMOCRATS AND CONGRESS HAVE
PROPOSED SPENDING ANOTHER
$12 MILLION TO INVESTIGATE
REPARATIONS FOR SLAVERY, JUST TO
GIVE YOU PROPORTION IN THE SENSE
OF THEIR PRIORITIES.
SO DEMOCRATS, EVERYTHING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN BORDER SECURITY.
THAT WILL BE FINE IF OUR CURRENT
SECURITY WAS WORKING.
IT'S NOT.
IN FACT, IT'S LIKELY THAT MORE
THAN 20 MILLION PEOPLE ALREADY
LIVE ILLEGALLY IN OUR COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S MORE THAN TWO AND A HALF
TIMES THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
NEW YORK CITY AND THE ACTUAL
NUMBER MAYING BIGGER THAN THAT.
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW AND THAT'S
THE POINT.
IT'S TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
THE PROBLEM IS BORDER PATROL
DOESN'T HAVE THE RIGHT
TECHNOLOGY TO DO THE JOB, THE
PROBLEM IS POLITICIANS DON'T
CARE TO FIX IT AND IF THEY DID,
THEY COULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM IN
AN AFTERNOON.
BORDERS ARE NOT THAT COMPLEX.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE TRYING TO
CURE PAN CREATIC CANCER HERE.
OUR BEST MINDS ARE STUMPED.
HARDLY.
IT WORKS FOR ISRAEL RIGHT NOW
AND A LOT OF OTHER PLACES.
WALLS WORK.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE STILL BUILT
THEM.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
THIS IS ALL A CHARADE AND WE
SHOULD AT LEAST ADMIT WHAT'S
HAPPENING Q. WHAT YOU SAW LAST
NIGHT WERE NOT TWO PARTIES
BICKERING OVER THE BEST WAY TO
SOLVE A SHARED PROBLEM.
NO, IN THIS CHARACTERS ONE
SIDE'S PROBLEM IS THE OTHER
SIDE'S SOLUTION.
FOR DEMOCRATS, A POROUS BOARD
SERAI GOOD THING.
GOOD THING.
MEANS LOW WAGE WHOA FOR THEIR
DONORS THAT'S CORRECT DEEPLY
APPRECIATED, MORE COMPLIANT THE
VOTERS FOR THEM TO, REPLACE THE
MILLIONS OF ACTUAL AMERICANS
THEY HAVE ALIENATED.
THEN THERE'S THE EMOTIONAL
PAYOFF OF THE WHOLE THING.
DEMOCRATS FEEL GOOD ABOUT LET IN
POOR PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE
WORLD.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO DON'T MAKE
A LOT COMPLICATED DEMANDS ABOUT
HEALTHCARE OR UNFUNDED DENTAL --
THEY ARE NOT WHINEY LIKE
AMERICANS.
THEY ARE NOT LIVING REMINDERS OF
HOW POLITICIANS FAILED TO
FULFILL THEIR PROMISES THEY WERE
JUST GRATEFUL TO BE HERE .
THEY'RE IMMIGRANTS.
DEMOCRATS LOVE PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
THEY HAVE COME TO LOVE THEM MUCH
MORE THAN THEY LOVE YOU.
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ SAID THAT OUT LOUD
LAST NIGHT.
>> THE WOMEN AND CHILDREN ON
THAT BOARD THAT ARE TRYING TO
SEEK REFUGE, AND SEEK
OPPORTUNITY IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, WITH NOTHING BUT THE
SHIRT ON THEIR BACKS, ARE ACTING
MORE AMERICAN THAN ANY PERSON
WHO SEEKS  TO KEEP THEM OUT EVER
WILL BE.
>> SO PEOPLE WHO SHOW UP HERE
AND IGNORE OUR LAWS ARE MORE